fast alles was wir machen braucht
mittlerweile strom und jeder kennt man
ist jetzt im sommer draußen und
plötzlich geht da handy-akku leer oder
die welt geht da mal wieder runter unter
stromnetz fällt einfach aus was macht
man da wie schwer es für den absolut
notwenig also einen kompletten leyen im
ernstfall aus total grundlegenden
bauteilen die manet zuhause rumliegen
hat oder teilen die man zu null vom
schrottplatz kriegen würde wie
kupferkabel magnets holzplatte nennen
generator zu bauen also ein gerät mit
dem man einfach kostenlos umsonst sein
handy aufladen oder licht machen kann
und zwar 100 prozent autark vom
stromnetz unabhängig und hat auch 100
prozent klimaneutral kann ich einfach so
meine eigenen strom machen durch kurbeln
dieses video wird unterstützt von
cyberghost vpn es gibt jetzt als aller
erstes mal das wovon ich denke wie ein
generator funktioniert ist wirklich sehr
wenig aus der schule hängen geblieben
ich weiß das ist halt irgendwie auf
jeden fall eine spule geben wird da und
natürlich ein plus pole und minuspol man
muss theoretisch hier so einen magneten
glaube ich hin und her bewegen und
dadurch wird dann strom induziert und
das ding läuft natürlich muss man dann
irgendwie hast du vielleicht zonen radny
oder machst du da jetzt ein haufen
magneten daran dass da ganz ganz viele
magneten sind ja genau dann hast halt
hier so ein ding hier von mir aus einer
kurbel in der kurbel dreht ja dann das
ganze ding hier in dem rat noch ein paar
speichern sie irgendwo sondern dresden
an der kurbel dass das ding dann in
irgendeine richtung sich bewegt sondern
gehen über die maria rain zur kanzel
durch kugeln strom erzeugen oder dann
schauen wir doch mal wie ich falsch ich
damit lag stimmt der trick war nicht
dass sich magnet durch eine spule durch
bewegt sondern dass ich in der
stromleitung durch ein magnetfeld durch
bewegt aber so von der grundidee weiß
jetzt gar nicht so falsch aber dann
brauche ich dafür eigentlich nur ein
stück draht und magneten und das war's
ganz so simpel ist es dann doch nicht
aber es stimmt das ganze basiert auf der
tatsache dass wenn man einen elektrisch
leitenden gegenstand durch ein
magnetfeld bewegt in diesem elektronen
verschoben werden der grund dafür ist
die lorenz kraft aber wir sind hier
nicht im physikunterricht für uns ist
nur wichtig dass es funktioniert wenn
man jetzt diesen leitenden gegenstand
ganz oft zu einer sogenannten spule
aufgewickelt zum beispiel 100 mal dann
passiert das ganze 100 mal so stark
zumindest von der idee her und diesen
induzierten strom können wir dann
benutzen das ist dann aber noch ein
ziemlich chaotischer wechselstrom und um
den in den gleichstrom zu verwandeln mit
dem usb-geräte bedient werden brauche
ich noch ganz viel schnickschnack aus
der elektrotechnik
aber dazu später mehr ich gehe mal
shoppen alles was ich mir kaufen könnte
man zur not übrigens auch aus dem ganzen
elektrisch potenz nehmen den ich sowieso
noch im keller herum liegen habe aber da
gerade nicht wirklich eine apokalypse
stattfindet nutze ich lieber so lange
ich noch kann die bestehende
infrastruktur und wir stellen wir die
teile einfach nach kurzer recherche
steht fest dass ich einmal der antik
idiot bin dass ich mit einem
selbstgemachten generator machen will
weil alle anleitungen die kaufen sich
einfach ein generator ja und ich muss
jetzt den und die spulen natürlich
selber hinkriegen das waren jetzt fünf
stunden in denen ich recherchiere was
ich dafür alles für zeugt brauche oder
das wurde echt wir ja auch mal sich
jetzt ein feuerlöscher organisiert dass
wir so krank
also ich fühle mich bei dem zeug was ich
gerade bestellt einfach so als würde ich
einen anzug zusammenbasteln ich erstmals
breit und hoch dass die sachen recht
schnell geliefert werden
[Musik]
so die kupferkabel sind jetzt an der
stelle auch mal da magnet habe ich noch
ganz ganz viele von merckle den ich
entwickelt habe ich habe aber auch noch
viel mächtigere auf die inszenierung
wurde stück größer sind und dadurch auch
mehr strom generieren werden
wahrscheinlich bei uns im generator hier
wir sind jetzt übrigens auch schon die
neue werkbank steht für diese art videos
die beiden schiffe sind schon hier aber
die holzplatte noch nicht dass ich hab
hier so'n also ein pressspan holz als
übergangssaison ich habe mich einfach
drauf jetzt einfach mal drauf los zu
legen hier mit einem draht und magnet
einfach irgendwie strom zu erzeugen aber
davor muss natürlich erst mal
herausfinden wie man strom überhaupt
nichts und das geht sogar super easy die
stromspannung einfach das rote kabel
hier und das schwarze kabel hier ein
donnern auf volt einstellen und dann an
plus und minuspol halten für den
widerstand stelle ich den regler einfach
auf und für die stromstärke auf ampere
wobei hier das rote kabel einmal
hierüber gesteckt wird
aber es kann ja eigentlich nicht so
leicht sein oder angaben ich mir jetzt
mal hier wollt messen die stromspannung
stehe jetzt mal dass an den lustigen
klemmen hier
obwohl ich mir mal so ein kupfer draus
wo das ja schön dass ne geile farbe dann
wirklich mal ein bisschen kupfer hier um
so ein stift jetzt eine spule dann
klatsche ich mal die klemmen einmal
zweimal also ohne theorie wenn ich den
letzten magneten darüber tisch soll dann
strom weg gehen funktioniert aber nicht
ich verstehe es nicht
[Musik]
okay wir sind jetzt seit monaten eine
bohrmaschine und wenn das jetzt hier
kein aufschlag bringt dann weil sie nie
mehr was außerdem was machen wir falsch
aber an sich erstmal eine batterie halt
gut dass jetzt durchgeschmort aber an
für sie funktioniert ist ob jetzt einmal
kaputt gegangen ist muss nicht mehr
aufpassen sich machen was mache ich
falsch
ich hab gerade mit elektrizität entdeckt
haben dazu gedacht habt ihr vielleicht
waren sie einmal zu wenige wicklungen
und dann war schon draußen dran jetzt zu
wickeln visum weltmeister ist mir
aufgefallen ich hab ich ja schon von der
spule der jetzt auch ins messgerät
angesteckt und wenn ich jetzt hier mit
magneten reinfahren
da habe ich ihn ausschlagen wieviel volt
bis zu 0,5 wodka seien ja kann nur sein
und das ist schon echt nicht schlecht
weil von 0,5 vollkommen auch ganz leicht
auf 5 volt und damit kann man sich heute
schon so einfach aufladen und ich bin
zwar geil und jetzt kriegt hier sogar
aus charme einer selbst gebauten schule
so da war ja geht doch und da kann man
loslegen damit dass mit dem kleinen
lämpchen klappt brauchen wir also spulen
mit einer hohen entwicklung und damit
ich nicht wirklich 3 oder 600 mal einen
draht herum micky muss gestalte ich
zuerst ganz grob auf papier und dann am
computer ein kleines gerät genau für
diesen zweck übrigens diesmal in einem
richtigen cad programm für produktdesign
und so welches ich erst vor kurzem
gelernt habe genau für diese art von
videos die bauteile werden anschließend
im 3d drucker gedruckt und dann zu einem
apparat zusammengebaut mit dem ich jetzt
hoffentlich die harte arbeit von einer
bohrmaschine erledigen lassen kann
so wie man loslegen woanders ehrgeizig
aber genau hinschauen do not get das
funktioniert echt gut jetzt ist sie
genau 1 cm dick aber nächstes muss man
sich natürlich rausnehmen und das hab
ich natürlich gar nicht gedacht das ist
jetzt schwierig ok hab ich echt schon
überdacht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
los geht's mit dem bau des generators
den ich ebenfalls zuerst auf papier und
dann am pc gestaltet
im prinzip besteht der hauptteil des
generators also zum einen aus einer fest
im boden verankerten 15 cm scheiber mit
18 stäben und passenden einlassungen für
die spuren sowie 18 kleine steck köpfe
die ich hier gerade vom druck brett
entfernen die die spulen an ihrem platz
halten sollen zum anderen gehört noch
eine rotierende scheibe mit zwölf
vertiefungen für magnete dazu und einem
kleinen loch damit man die magnete
leicht wieder raus schieben kann und
natürlich einen sockel in denen das
ganze fest verankert wird schließlich
wollen wir später mit einem extrem
gehebelten zahnrad system enorme
drehzahlen erreichen
[Musik]
das geniale ist wenn wir erst an den
generator haben ist es ja egal woher die
drehbewegung kommt das heißt wir können
später auch wind und wasserkraft
ausprobieren ob kurbel fahrer dynamo
wasserkraft windkraft atomkraft das
prinzip ist immer gleich wobei man für
atomkraft plutonium anreichern müsste
und das soll ich jetzt vielleicht nicht
einfach so gut wenn ich nicht will dass
man internet anbieter denkt dass ich
sonst was vorhaben das würde ich dann
lieber nur mit dem vpn machen mit dem
von cyberghost vpn in unserem heutigen
sponsoren damit gehe nämlich alle
anfragen über den sicheren vpn-tunnel
wodurch die eigene ip-adresse versteckt
und verschlüsselt ist mit cyberghost vpn
könnte aber auch kuhglocken umgehen und
serien und filme auf 38
streaming-diensten wie netflix und
wissen die plast sehen die in
deutschland gesperrt sind indem wir den
anderen standort aus wie zb die usa und
alle apps und websites denken dann hier
kommt wirklich aus den usa und in
deutschland könnte sogar formel 1 wieder
kostenlos schauen beim österreichischen
sender orf der deutsche ohne vpn nämlich
raus spürt cyberghost vpn oder 36
millionen nutzer fünf sterne auf trust
pallett 24/7 deutschen support und eine
strikte neue loks policy das heißt nicht
mal die wissen was jemals cyberghost vpn
exil auf allen gängigen plattformen ohne
dürfte es mit einem account sogar mit
bis zu sieben freunden teilen wenn ihr
das ganze ausprobieren wollte jetzt 84
prozent über den link in der wie die
beschreibung und zahlt im monat für 195
und dank der 45 tage
geld-zurück-garantie ist das ganze auch
komplett risikofrei ganz im gegensatz zu
dem also jetzt gleich machen weswegen
ich tatsächlich diesen feuerlöscher
gekauft hat hat es jetzt ähnlich gedacht
ich habe immer gelegentlich sagen falsch
gemacht wusste dann neu machen ist mir
der größte feld passiert ich dachte erst
ich das so machen will dass ich die
spuren hier schnell drehen und die
magnete fest verankert sind
er ist mir aufgefallen wenn die spulen
sich drehen dann verhält sich ja die
ganzen karree und das war nicht so
schlau darum musste ich dann jetzt hier
nochmal bei den magneten verankerungen
absägen ja so gut aber jetzt kann es
auch schon losgehen jetzt kann man die
marine einsätzen ja das sieht gut aus
funktioniert mega erfolgreich ist die
folgenden raumschiffen wirklich also nur
vor
so jetzt aber richtig schwierig weil man
kann die dinge endlich alles reinlegen
gut man kann sich schon einmal einlegen
und funktioniert sogar auf was richtig
sparen ist wenn man jemanden hier rein
drückt sagt dann passende hier perfekt
rein richtig geil wenn ich sie sehr sehr
selten aus nur das problem ist die
müssen jetzt irgendwie geschalten werden
also die müssen verbunden werden und
irgendwie an die kabel und man kann ja
nicht einfach so zusammen stecken und
darauf hoffen dass es funktioniert und
ja jetzt muss ich mir das überlegen und
keinen plan machen jagd was ein
schaltplan machen na ja ein richtiger
schaltplan ist es jetzt nicht er eine
skizze in den beispielen am anfang waren
ist ja drei spielen nun ist das im
prinzip das gleiche denn von den 18
werden jeweils abwechselnd sechs spielen
zusammen geschlossen wodurch am ende
drei strom ausgänge haben hier also blau
orange und rot und das muss nun noch auf
die echten spulen angewendet werden
[Musik]
jetzt mal ganz unter uns ich habe keinen
plan ob das hier funktionieren werden
wir finden draußen auch zum letzten mal
vor sechs jahren in der schule getötet
ob das noch was wird wenn wir jetzt auch
auf die guten alten schrumpfschläuche
mann kennen die datenstruktur auch zu
hause ist gar kein problem damit haben
wir jetzt dem blau eingezeichnet den
schaltkreis an
ja sag mal hier die ganze spulen mit
tape anklebt damit die nicht so rum
wackeln let's go ich glaube es passt zu
meiner jetzt
wenn das geistig hatten schon das
ansteckt das funktioniert sogar das
heißt ich kann jetzt das teil der
darüber legen und dann schon mal drehen
und das generierte strom und derzeit
noch eine idee ich hab's mal
provisorisch ein kugellager angeschraubt
jetzt nur 0,5 wollte auf jeden fall
waren es kurz moa war damals gerade da
was gerade ein traum irgendwann wollt ja
damals schon wollte ok dass wir machen
ja noch dreimal so viel spielen und am
ende dreht sich das ganze ding ja noch
viel schneller
ja da bin ich gespannt das ist richtiger
korrekt einfach ich habe vorhin übrigens
hier so schrumpfschläuche drüber gemacht
zur isolierung in dem wir jetzt hier
noch schrumpfen das tun sie mit hitze
und dass man kämpfen und damit dass
kunst doch nicht schmerzt lege ich hier
mal so ein stück pappe darunter
da passt das nicht mega ist auf jeden
fall gut genug
und dass man jetzt aber im rest
so der teil ist schon mal fertig und das
finde ich super impressed jetzt will ich
mal sagen ist eine zeit das ganze ding
mal zusammen zu bauen damit wieder
langsam auch ein paar umdrehungen drauf
kriegen ja mehr als fundament da muss
jetzt das machen wir so ein stabilisator
ja und das meint erst mal rein das ginge
sie hält auch fest dass richtig geil
das hätte richtig fest super neues ging
erstaunlich easy school blogger passt ja
auch richtig rein hier kommt dann als
zweite kugel rein so und das muss jetzt
dran damit das funktioniert so gerne
drehen noch nicht mehr ganz schnell aber
selbst das sollte ich glaube ich schon
relativ fast zahlen hier ich muss auch
mal ein bisschen optimieren damit dass
gleich richtig unrund läuft schauen wie
viel strom das ding jetzt produziert
okay das insane
so aber da wenn ich das ding jetzt nur
so ganz langsam drehe ich schon nisi 0,5
volt hinkriegt die ganze zeit denke ich
dass ich das aber immer wenn ich
schneller drehen würde aber ich das
ganze dem aufrichtigen drei strom
abschalte richtig richtig viel volt
rauskriegen würde womit locken handy
oder sonstwas betreiben könnte was
richtig geil werfen würde ich sagen ich
hab ich mir jetzt mal eine platine und
sorgt dafür dass das ganze teil nicht
irgendwie ein komisches durchwachsenen
wechselstrom raus haut sondern halten
saubere in gleichstrom
[Musik]
wir machen wieder fünf uhr morgens aber
da kommt richtig den gleichstrom aus
drei wollt ihr wollt den ball vor oder
wir testen das ist für so eine kleine
ging wende reicht guck mal das ist
richtig in szene
das egal wenn ich alles gebe und die
scheibe schnell drehe bekommen wir jetzt
5 volt und ca 0,05 ampere aber die
geschwindigkeit können wir noch deutlich
erhöhen hierfür baue ich ein system mit
einem kleinen und einem großen zahnrad
und einer stabilen vorrichtung alter
profi habe ich mich wieder eingelassen
sind gerade fünf hohen acht ich glaub
ich hab jetzt alle teilen
morgen muss er so alles verbaut werden
und dann glaube ich bin glaube ich kann
ich strom erzeugen alleine schon krass
ernstfall kratzt nicht also ist schon
ein bisschen solarium ein feeling
aufkommt wenn hier so nachts so
mechanisches zeug zusammen schuster das
zahnrad jahren viermal so großen
durchmesser wie das kleine zahnrad ihr
das heißt wenn sich das große zahnrad
einmal dreht hat sich der selben zeit
das kleine vier mal gedreht und dadurch
sollten wir hier viel mehr power
reinkriegen also man jetzt natürlich als
aller erstes mal das zahnrad hier
einfach dran
[Musik]
den ball trat gesehen geht es vielleicht
noch ein bisschen sogar mehr habe ich ja
immer so eine zweite scheibe und das hat
sich jetzt noch mal auch magnet zu
wollen das kann sich auch wieder super
schnell hat man muss man doch noch mein
plan ist nehme ich jetzt nicht nur eine
seite mit magneten zu haben sondern
einfach direkt von beiden seiten das
sorgt für ein stärkeres magnetfeld
anfang das magnetfeld mal so ein
bisschen so visualisieren habe ich immer
so ein fluid ist eine flüssigkeit und
das sieht einfach richtig krass aus und
hier sieht man richtig gut wieder quasi
die magnetfelder sich verhalten genau
und dieses mal fällt düster jetzt quasi
immer an den spuren vorbei das ist
richtig so wie halt einfach das ding
kommt jetzt daran
mal schauen ob die zweite scheibe etwas
gebracht hat hat das gebracht wir kommen
auf 15 volt was schon in 10 ist und man
merkt doch richtig das ist wie eine
gangschaltung bei einem auto ist wenn
ich jetzt hier einfach kurbel und das
halberg nehmen kann ich aber danach
wieder einfädeln und wir wollen und
hätte ich da jetzt ein größeres zahnrad
dann hätte ich da auch noch mal eine
deutlich größere umsetzung nachschauen
ob das ding jetzt mein handy aufwarten
kann ist let's go ich hab mir so ein
altes usb verlängerungskabel benutze ich
nie weil es hier echt und würde sagen
wir köpfen das mal und da mal was da
drin ist
jetzt haben wir es im fall gelegtes
kabel jetzt natürlich gar kein plan wohl
für diese vier kabel überhaupt sind mir
hilft auch die natürlich mal wieder und
roland schwarz in energie und grün und
das sind daten so also wenn es jetzt
klappt wäre richtig geil passen dabei
haben wir auch hier in schwachen akku
mit 4 prozent
aber an für sich soll das gehen da ist
auch mal strom drauf wir haben auch
recht hohe volt sein also handys sind
echt ultra anspruchsvoll was das angeht
ich kriege auch nicht hin ich habe jetzt
noch das hier gefunden usb ventilator
theoretisch sollte das nicht
funktionieren und in der praxis auf
[Applaus]
also der hier der super entspannt
ich glaube dass wenn ich einfach sich am
generator eine propeller an bringen
würde dass es dann nicht mehr
hingegen würde letzte versuch alte
kaputte bänke ausgekannt und einfach
dieses steuer ding abgezwackt von der
batterie
ja da stürzt sich jetzt aber mein ding
heran und hoffe dann dass ich hier
einstellen kann uns funktioniert muss ja
nicht schön sein oder funktionieren und
jetzt glaube ich kann man das testen
stellt erst mal wieder den kollegen hier
an wird er sich drehen macht dann nicht
mehr herum aber weil ich also es ist
echt und was man schwierig gerade jetzt
bei so nem iphone und so weiter und so
fort apple hat also wie sollen wir so
ein mega die hohen anforderungen
irgendwie komisch im kabel dass sie auch
ja nicht irgend jemand nachmachen kann
dass man auch ja deren produkte kaufen
muss und so weiter und so fort und das
jetzt hier zu simulieren ist natürlich
ultra ultra kompliziert ist schon als
erster kommentar des videos irgendwas
super einfach ist was ich machen müssen
aber ich komme ich brauch' ich habe ewig
im internet recherchiert also so lange
zeit eine woche möglich ist und ich muss
sagen dass mit dem handy klappt leider
nicht aber ich würde sagen ja ein
bisschen spaß oder
manchmal schauen ich will mir hier raus
kriegen also 15
[Musik]
das wagenrad 20 volt 0,3 ampere ja also
ich weiß es nicht ich würde das fällt
nicht auf vollgas da mal hin die
ansteckung ist eine schlechte idee 20
wochen ein bisschen zu viel
so also ich habe nichts gemacht
es werde nie wieder im dunklen filmen
müssen wir würde mich auch nie
wiederholen müssen
es ist schon hell und ich würde sagen
irgendwann auch mal ein zwei kriegs auch
hin dass das ding mal hinten aufnehmen
zum beispiel für den die beschreibung
weil ich mit dem schon bald wissen es
darum geht wie sie für nikolov gegeben
vielen dank noch mal an cyberghost fürs
unterstützen dieses videos in link zum
vpn mit 84 prozent rabatt und den ersten
vier monate gratis findet in der video
beschreibung so ein video das hier mache
ich fast jede woche also abonniert gerne
signal
und dann sieht man es mal wieder macht
es gut
[Musik]